because of unprecedented flooding rock
slides and mudslides this is new video
now just look at this this is being
caused by the large amount of rain they
got there recently
there's no word on when the park will
open back up wow
what i'm thinking there's a lot of bison
in yellowstone so i hope they're okay
because there's a there's a lot of
flooding there going on right now that
unusual this time of year i mean very
unusual that's all from what we call
atmospheric river so that's why seattle
they've been drenched and pacific
northwest has been drenched and the
tough part is that kids are out of
school so they're all probably wanted to
go to yellowstone park you know how many
people have reservations yes because
this time of the year you're thinking
hey
navigate that power of water too you see
how fast it's moving yeah and we go
through that here during monsoon season
which starts next month so getting ready
for that all right look outside right
now this is our rio tower cam guys
another uh great day today and i say
that because you're probably thinking
yeah it's hot but not quite as excessive
as it was last week that's because the
temperatures have dropped as we promised
now down to 95 degrees this is still
very warm but again out of the dangerous
heat all right 10 humidity look at that
70 degrees cooler than yesterday this
time still a little breezy outside
nothing gusty like we had early this
morning 91 in summerlin at this hour new
neighborhoods here to show you downtown
double nines for you you're still the
century mark for nellis and sunrise
manor 94 rhodes ranch mountains ed
southern highlands same for you 97
henderson we're about 94 degrees also
for silverado ranch and 97 also for
green valley 94 for prep 107 death
valley still hot no doubt about it there
91 in indian springs 91 also search
light in sandy valley you're checking in
right now 95 degrees satellite and radar
dry here but if you look towards utah
got a couple lightning strikes here
right around brinehead and what's
happening is that front is starting to
slide through and down towards us and it
does that lift creates some of these
thunderstorms that we're seeing not
going to get that but we are going to
get strong winds tonight here's where
we're seeing the severe weather right
now that we'll have to watch this
evening pass through chicago pastor
cincinnati this area is still under the
bull's-eye for possible violent
thunderstorms that could be
that could spawn tornadoes for at least
early evening wind forecast does show i
want to show you your neighborhoods here
because by tonight look at this we're
going to get some pretty good gusts in
some neighborhoods specifically to the
north and towards the west side of town
at least according to our wind cast this
is by the time i go on for eight news
now at 11 so be sure to tune in at that
time at 11 o'clock tonight because we'll
get some gusty winds and then tomorrow
morning a little breezy tomorrow
afternoon those winds should start to
subside here more so hey better chance
to go for that morning jogging that
morning walk or walk the dogs because
we're out of that excessive heat so now
your morning hours are good for that
little exercise by 10 am 11 am just
getting a little too warm and then i say
by noontime yeah keep it all indoors at
that time no heat alerts have been
issued thankfully so here's what to
expect for tonight temperatures will be
warm not quite as warm as last week 93
at 9 o'clock 8 news now eleven eighty
seven degrees but we will have gusty
winds for this evening here is your
eight day forecast here on channel eight
temperatures will peak at on thursday
107 like we talked about then dropping
look at that back down to 95 just in
time for dad's day that's your most
accurate weather update brian denise are
you